was once considered a beacon of
democracy
who stood up to the country's powerful
military leaders
now that military has seized control and
arrested her
replacing her with a military general
it says the action is legally justified
but many
reject that there are concerns as an
institution
that the election results will trigger
uh government policies that will weaken
the military's power in the system
i think everyone in myanmar understands
that that they're using the law
to their advantage the coup is a
culmination of a turbulent relationship
between
tsuchi and the military that's been
going on for decades
tsuchi is the daughter of the late
nationalist leader aung sang
and she spent much of her youth overseas
she returned home in 1988 when she
joined student-led
protests against the military that had
taken power in a 1962
coup the movement was crushed and
hundreds of protesters killed
a year later she was imprisoned in her
family home
and would spend 15 years in detention
[Music]
in 2010 the military released suchi who
walked free among
large crowds of supporters
it is difficult to achieve democracy and
after we achieve democracy
it is hard to maintain we have to do a
lot of work
and we have to take things slowly
in an historic shift from military rule
suchi's national democratic party came
to power
in 2015. she became state councillor and
the de facto leader of myanmar but after
five decades in power
the military maintained much control
[Music]
the constitution allowed it control of
defense and interior ministries
and it was guaranteed a quarter of seats
in parliament
that gave it enough power to veto
changes to the constitution
suchi is extremely popular in myanmar
in 2019 she appeared in the
international court of justice
where she defended the military against
allegations
of genocide in 2020's november election
her ndl party won a landslide victory
the military claimed the win was
fraudulent
just over two months later it seized
power by force
provoking widespread criticism
suchi's previous detention did little to
undermine her popularity
but now it's unclear how active and
vocal
her supporters will be under threat of
military action
laura about manly al jazeera
not speak to david matheson who's a
yangon based analyst of myanmar he's
joining us from chiang mai in thailand
thanks for speaking to us on the
newshour so we have a situation now
where the military
is saying that it will hold on to power
for one year and then it will pass it on
to the civilian government
how likely is that
well whenever militaries stage a coup
and set a time limit
um i think it's fair to say don't trust
them um once they get a taste of power
i i don't think whatever time frame um
that they commit to can actually be
trusted
um you know and all of these promises
that we're seeing coming out today that
they want to hold another election
and and and all of these things this is
fundamentally a naked grab at power
and i don't think that the commander and
chief and those close to him can be
trusted anymore to actually
so what do you think their longer game
plan is
i i think holding on to power and and
basically shifting things
um to maintain their interests now
conventional wisdom
last week was that they've got it so
good anyway why would they actually
stage occur
um well obviously their calculations are
a much different i think that they can
better serve their interests um
holding on to power like this and um and
unfortunately the democratic progress of
the country will suffer
i mean that's the thing you talk about
their interest but they already had
um significant power and they were
looking after their interests in myanmar
so
just a few days ago they also appeared
to walk back threats of a coup
so why do you think they did this now
um i think it's it's it's essentially
about one man it's about the commander
achievement online
and he had no uh um he had no retirement
plan
he wanted to hold on to power and he
decided to take the entire institution
of
the military with it and he's been
setting up i think for several months
this very careful narrative
um that there was something deeply wrong
with the elections which is just not
true
um you know there were certainly
deficiencies but but the extent of
of the uh the malfeasance that the
military is is alleging
it's just not true i think this is all
about um the deluded grandeur of
one man and the fact that the military
thinks that it can actually advance its
interest
by holding on to you know all the levers
of power and unfortunately i think
that's going to be counterproductive
both for them but definitely for the
rest of the country what do you think
will happen on the ground because the
aung san tsuchi
the nld leader has called for protest do
you think people will
actually come out in protest
i think if you compare some of the
public um
outpouring of support for aung san
tsuchi and the nld ahead of the election
and the the jubilation over the the
landslide victory
um this is essentially a betrayal of all
of those people who voted for hong kong
sochi
so i i do expect some backlash people
will be furious
throughout the country i mean there is
no way that the military can argue that
this was a close election
that there was um uh graft and fraud in
involved um which could question the
outcome
and so people will quite rightly see
this as
as a grab for power and that then the
military saw losers
um and and basically want to take over
the country again this is a massive
leap backwards and and people have been
used to their freedoms over the past 10
years
and the military is directly challenging
the people it's not just an elite grab
of power
this is the military challenging most of
the people of myanmar what do you think
the range of options will be for the
international community to consider i
mean some countries have
already weighed in some countries in
europe as well as the secretary of state
in the united states
i think that there is no other choice
but for widespread condemnation
across the board um you know japan was
one of the first countries to endorse
the elections after they were held in
november
i think they're going to be exasperated
by what's going on because they've been
a big supporter of aung san suchi and
they've tried to engage with the
military to a certain extent
i think china will just be um really
quite
exhausted um with the inability of the
military to actually
be rational actors for the west i think
it's going to be a massive betrayal
over all the support that the western
donors have given to this democratic
transition over
over the past decade i think uh the
countries of southeast asia will be
really quite um quite frustrated with
um with the myanmar military for for
doing this um
and certainly at a time during the
pandemic and lots of
um of economic crises going on this just
makes
um the military look um incredibly
uh bad faith in in in their commitment
to
to democracy and it makes them look
incompetent so i think the the
international community correction is
going to be
very very negative and for lots of
countries like the united states and
australia
there's probably legal triggers that
will have to come into force because of
a coup d'etat
um so this will further serve to isolate
me am i just to the time
which was it was opening up to the world
over the past several years
all right thank you so much david
matheson for speaking to us from
thailand